interest rates they are going up the
question is when and how fast at the
moment markets are expecting the first
increase to come next spring that's
around februari or march barts they'll
be going up gradually only rising two
about 2% by 2020 that doesn't sound too
painful given that it wasn't all that
long ago that the normal level for
interest rates was considered to be
about five percent the difference is
that today there are a lot of households
facing high debt loads with mortgages
and credit cards the Bank of England
reckons that even if rates go up to 2.5
percent the number of households facing
high debt levels will only go up from
one-point-three percent to one point
eight percent however some think that
understates the potential amount of
strain first remember the interest rate
you pay is generally higher than the
official bank rate second even those
official rates could easily go higher
maybe above three percent if rates do go
that high some think the number of
households spending more than a third of
their post tax income on mortgage
repayments could more than double from
1.1 million now to 2.3 million but most
economists think it's not going to
overturn the economy and for savers who
have had many years of such low interest
rates this will be something of a relief
but for the families who have borrowed a
lot it's going to be a serious wake-up
call